provato per il resto della vita come il
campione olimpico
probabilmente se nessuno mi batterà
questo record rimarrà l'unico al mondo
per vinto tutti i più grandi titoli sono
67 ma nel mio curriculum lo scrivo
sempre 250 volte ho perso qualcuno se ne
frega qualcun altro mi chiede di parte
chiaramente quello che vi sto per
raccontare una storia breve la faccio
anche in sintesi anche perché le mie
gare di 90 secondi quindi devo mettere
tanti anni per quella prestazione di 90
secondi solo sportiva e dura 90 secondi
nel 2007 aveva 23 anni
quindi all'apice della forza fisica
bello è bello aveva praticamente il
mondo sotto i piedi perché la più forte
atleta aveva una federazione che
lavorava solo per me avevo la moto avevo
2 3 1 rosa insomma per avere padrone del
mondo poteva acquistare qualsiasi cosa e
perché mai era segnato da un paio d'anni
e mi svegliavo la mattina e vedremo una
cosa che brillava adesso lunga sulla
destra che era una medaglia olimpica e
radio io avevo stato fare questo
percorso questo sentiero per prenderla
2007 l'anno preolimpico prima di pechino
una settimana prima delle selezioni
nazionali per essere quindi nella
squadra nazionale quindi devo soltanto
fare la passeggiatina per poi andare
mondiali qualificate per questo
olimpiadi la settimana prima prendo la
mia moto chiamerà i miei amici i ragazzi
oggi andiamo piano perché una settimana
mi già compagno futuro unicamente che
vediamo in moto cosa succede che guarda
un po cellini valli e montagne tanti
accordi che c'è una curva a sinistra poi
sono un'altra e non la fai ti appoggio è
un merito la moto non succede niente
proprio toccato li avevate con l'inerzia
tutelato parte del muretto 7 metri sotto
c'era un torrente in secca
in quel momento ho sentito un lavoro
questa del mio angelo custode che mi ha
permesso di essere qui oggi perché
davvero se vedete il posto o
impressionante fatto sta che mi alzo
guarda in su vedo questo momento vedo i
miei amici con questi occhi così
arriveremo mi arrampico per questo
momento vivo che la moto è opposta sono
contento
poi arriva un po di tremare le gambe
caldo che dietro
fatto sta che mi risveglio in ospedale
disteso o le dimissioni il mio angelo
custode infatti da poco ritrovato più
moto è successo perché non riesco tanto
a bovino è il medico ne fa serramenti
lei per 90 giorni dell'estate disteso
capita che io ero acquistare il mondo
esso non mi sono trovato nel letto
d'ospedale con questo verdetto del
master dottore ho cominciato a scalare
per ball e ancora più in basso la certo
ecco la medaglia non avevo più era lì
ogni mattina mi allenavo e dai reali ma
non la vedo più quattro giorni dopo metà
chiaramente cominci a pensare tutte le
varie opzioni va beh studierò finora le
università farò altre cose non troverà
una ricca insomma ci sta che non l'avevo
di fare qualsiasi pensiero è per tirarmi
su
ma non ci riusciva a parte ma erano 68
anni che mi allenavo il medico federale
mi guarda negli occhi forse per
convincermi perdiamo posto morale mi
dice premana le 45 giorni facciamo una
prova se eravate barriere barba
fatturata insomma se si è consolidata
tempo che lavora in acqua
nello stesso momento mi chiama da una
federazione dicendo momenti siccome sei
il nostro numero ognuno se la punta di
diamante io cominciavo a ringraziarmi
avevo scartato l'ultima selezione la
faremo quei giornali che l'ultima gara
che abbiamo a 100 giorni dall'incidente
quindi se non altro devo stare fermo poi
magari 45 in acqua dieci giorni per
tornare a ballare ma forse ce la faccio
anche quella che può più dire brillava
molto lontano perché mai dovrei togliere
st d'armi responsabilità io te lo dico
ci proviamo però 45 mamma mi preme ma
che ami porta in piscina entra vento
comincia a lavorare
vedo più veloce perché sono dei momenti
dove non li auguro a nessuno di voi
perché tu stai rincorrendo questo sogno
stai soffrendo perché gli errori fici si
fanno qualche affetto probabilmente ha
cominciato a vedere la cosa brillava per
qualche errore e mi è arrivata in
ospedale ma fatto state novantesimo
giovanni torna in calo ma fisicamente
non abbiamo perso contro chiaramente mi
mancava tutta la parte tecnica
sensibilità facendo 30 secondi e lamenta
perché dovevo scendere che stavo male il
mio allenatore lui si è resa conto di
quello che stavano facendo non certo a
crederci
forse più lui di me accostate al
centesimo giorno questa gara è arrivato
eravamo al menti gara benissimo
insomma sarà in formissima per la
pressione probabilmente mi ha fatto sì
che non sta con la gara pessima gli
altri per battermi hanno provato a fare
qualcosa di particolare ed eccezionale
alla fine ho vinto io mi qualifico per i
mondiali vado ai mondiali agopuntura e
medicina euro di tutto per me di tutto
lecito
quinto al mondiale mi qualifico per
pechino finalmente ricomincia a rivedere
quella medaglia mi risale leggo come
percorso che ho fatto
vado in cina comincia comincia le gare
faccio quello che devo fare sale
semifinale sono in finale sto per pagare
parte questa gara da cui però che le
tasse senza cominciano a essere convinto
che finalmente possono andare la mano e
prendere con la medaglia
il problema che per annullare quella
della mano dovevo uscire dalla barca e
l'ho fatto prima dell'arrivo a 20 metri
dall'arrivo nascondersi sono dei paletti
e praticamente faccia l'errore
banalissimo un errore che da vermelho
scritto in tanti ma cosa potete un santo
che è mangiato come mai tutte entrate la
nell'aria non fa riuscito per la
sconfitta clamorosa papera non è uno dei
favoriti insomma avere una pressione
dietro non tanto su di me
insomma era uno di quelli che doveva
prendere quella medaglia passa all
angolo ogni tre giorni sono per smaltire
mi sveglio con la mattina deluso è
chiaramente non voglio solo ritornare a
casa
anzi gli occhi e vedo che brilla ancora
c'è scritto per a londra
chiamo il mio allenatore per guarda io
ci pensate non so perché però so che
posso farcela lo stesso so che se
dall'incidente e dall'insieme sono
arrivato qua perché non era pronto come
persona qui non era pronto come atleta
aiutami l'allenatore da 13 medaglia
olimpica l'ha vinta vent'anni prima di
londra nel 92 e dai libri di un percorso
m io in quel momento con le mattine cina
ne sarebbero subito maturare
agonisticamente sono uscito dall essere
il campione proprio di avere quel
medaglia al collo e ha cominciato a
essere un po più umile e come c'è da
dire cos'è che mi manca cosa ho
sbagliato essere consapevole delle cose
che in quel momento mi mancano la
palestra del campione perché si fa le
prestazioni e vinci qualche garetta sei
più forte fisicamente ma nello sport che
ci giochiamo le medaglie centesimi
sapete sono quelle piccole cose che
fanno la differenza con le piccole cose
sono appreso ha cominciato a ricercare
ho fatto oggi che è meglio saranno
diventato il manager di me stesso ho
fatto la mia squadra il mio medico
psicologo sportivo cosa da costruire dal
2009 prima europeo quel mondiale a coppa
il mondo stanno arrivando stava
maturando partenope membri quelli è
arrivata perché davvero ho fatto la mia
prestazione con un dato la mano e ho
preso quella medaglia nello sport
cattivo cattivo perché le olimpiadi non
c'è nessuno che va per arrivare secondo
sono tutti forti fisicamente preparati
tecnicamente motivati
la differenza io so l'ho fatta quattro
anni prima quando da quella sconfitta e
mi sono reso conto che era un po proprio
arrogante quell'arroganza che da film
fastidio dice volevano i link proprio
non l'ho fatto
a londra invece l'ho fatto da quella
sconfitta data da un percorso dove da da
23enne avrò il mondo mi sono trovato a
letto d'ospedale enel ma costa perché
poi sono convinto di vincere non vinco
devo fare un passo indietro deve parlare
uomo
io sono ancora quello che tutti si
aspettano
io non sono ancora quello che faccio
vedere la ragazza che solo allora provo
eliminare tutte queste cose tutto questo
egoismo perché la fine egoismo e ha
cominciato a imparare da quel momento ho
cominciato a maturare ho cominciato a
costruire piano piano nei momenti un
uomo daniele un nuovo atleta e non penso
di essere un talento perché a 14 anni
minimi mi schianta lì e non riuscivo a
saltare nemmeno m nel salto in lungo ma
da quelle sconfitti da quel momento
cominciato a costruire il campione che
poi è uscito gli ho parlato casa col
risultato di un po
l'augurio che faccio è chiaro che con lo
sconto è facile fare degli esempi perché
ti alleni risultato ce l'hai
sì sì quasi sempre però io possa essere
un esempio di quello che allenandosi non
c'è riuscito ha dovuto imparare da
quell'errore da quella sconfitta deve
essere tornato tornato umano per poi
cominciare quel percorso che
costruendolo da manager come fa
un'azienda davvero avevo il mio budget
devo fare determinate cose molto
minuzioso se vogliamo doveva essere di
avere molto in cercare i particolari
perché da avere alimentato ingegnere per
costruirmi la barca su misura prima peso
allora avevo 10 parte lo stile scartati
per arrivare a quella giusta aveva una
dieta e per gli utili 30 giorni non
dovevo sgarrare proprio perché volevo
essere sicuro che niente fosse lasciato
al caso fatto la casualità esistano ma
c'è un modo per superarle io lo farei
uscito sono riuscito con dei medici che
mi hanno dato fiducia sono riuscito
comodo e ben killer di antidolorifici
importanti però sono riuscito ed è la
cosa che più importante che fa lo sport
che mi abbia fatto su di me mi ha fatto
crescere come uomo mi ha fatto capire
che qualsiasi sogno sentivo trasformi
come obiettivo
e ci lavori contesta con metodo poi
veloce raggiungere qualsiasi cosa ci
sono le persone che ti aiutano a
ritrovare quelle giuste si ballerà e
continuare a sbagliare ripeto di quei
quattro anni prima di londra ne ho vinte
tante ma ne ho perse molte di più ad
ogni sconfitta giungeva piccoli tasselli
per costruire quel campione che poi è
venuto fuori da qui che faccia proprio
presto siate contenti quando siete in
down e proprio da lì potete risalire
siate contenti quando sbagliate qualcosa
perché proprio da lì riuscirete a
imparare a noi fare lo stesso errore nel
mio mio sport io sono riuscito e verrà
ricordato per per quella medaglia
non mi piace di più ricordare le 250
volte che ho perso perché lì mi hanno
fatto diventare l'uomo che sono il
campione che sono stato per esempio che
magari per qualcuno di voi questa la
spinta per diventare una persona
migliore in bocca al lupo
[Applauso]